ciao a tutti i ragazzi a loro oggi ho
deciso di fare un video diverso dal
solito perché oggi in realtà inizia un
esperienza diversa dal solito tra un
mese infatti debutterà a teatro
con grease nei panni di danny zucco la
compagnia della rancia la regia è di
saverio marconi e adesso trovarmi io a
essere il protagonista di musical così
importante mi ha fatto pensare una cosa
e allora anche un lama può essere
beyoncé se gli metti la parrucca giusta
in testa no scherza non era questo ogni
volta che a me capita e tagliare un
traguardo così importante mi trovo
spesso a riflettere sul mio strano
rapporto con le passioni adesso mi
spiego per ogni mio sogno c'è sempre
stato un incubo ad aspettarmi ogni cosa
che in teoria doveva farmi stare meglio
mi faceva stare peggio io calcolate che
per anni io mi sono detto dino essere
abbastanza mi sono flagellato mi sono
detto che non
che numeri non mi meritavo nulla e che
mai aver ottenuto nulla assolutamente
era arrivato in un momento di follia
assurdo nel quale pensavo che se io non
avessi desiderato nulla allora così non
avrei subito delusioni essere stato
felice per sempre e quindi magari da
fuori qualcuno poteva vedermi come un
ragazzino lunatico silenzioso però
dentro
in realtà quella l'iran ha una maschera
per pelle nasconde in realtà quelle che
erano le mie insicurezze la mia rabbia
la mia frustrazione e quindi ero in
questo gruppo pazzesco nel quale mi
dicevo non seguire quello che anni
perché tanto quando poi chi chi ci mette
il cuore tu sei solamente più esposto si
è più fragile persone di possono
schiacciare in due secondi si vanno a
toccarti in quel momento là fuori nel
mondo ci sono persone che meritano molto
più amore molto più cibo molto più
sostegno multe o molte più opportunità
di quelle che sono state date a me lo
stesso ragazzino pieno di paure pieno di
di insicurezze qual cosa assurda è che
io sognavo di fare musical da quando
cantavo le canzoni della disney mi
immaginavo nei panni di ariel caracappa
monnezza ecco perché ci tenevo a dire
una cosa a te che stai guardando questo
video è proprio magari non ci siamo mai
conosciuti come ancora incrociati nella
vita o magari solo di sfuggita ecco io
ti auguro chiama col cuore lo faccio
veramente ti auguro davvero tanto
di trarre forza dalle tue passioni e
spero veramente questo è un ti bruciano
ma io che ho che tu non finisca per
pensare che non ne valga la pena perché
chi giornale vale sempre la pena sempre
sempre sempre soprattutto quando
penserai che il destino abbia messo il
nulla di speciale da parte del tempo sta
diventando sempre più drammatica questa
luce
fatemi fare un cambiamento io ci tenevo
veramente a ringraziarvi per il sostegno
che mi avete che mi avete proprio
dimostrato in nove anni cioè i ragazzi
nove anni cioè ci sono persone che mi
seguono da nove anni non so ancora rotto
i [ __ ] di me io se avessi aperte un
mio video dopo tre secondi misere
mandato affanculo ha chiuso questo video
io ribadisco che ci terrei tantissimo se
venisse a vedermi a teatro anche se non
ho capito se l'idea mi dà carica o un mi
terrorizza ancora non lo so non ho
deciso
ho chiesto di poter fare avere alle
persone che mi seguono uno sconto
infatti qua sotto c'è un un link con
proprio un codice da mettere se volete
uno sconto il problema è che non durerà
per sempre forse non mi ricordo quando
finisce per insomma sbrigate cercherò di
documentare il più possibile questa
esperienza di portarli con me fare
vedere un pochino che cosa faccio e
niente fino fino ad allora io vi auguro
il meglio veramente
ribadisco quello che era l'augurio di
prima
niente ci vediamo al prossimo video
questo punto ciao
[Musica]